The ECB's main task is to ensure prices in the euro area remain stable,...
...keeping inflation at a reasonable target rate of around 2%.
It does this by fixing interest rates.
These decisions have a direct impact on the credit policies...
...of the banking institutions.
For example, in the case of overheating eurozone economies,...
...the ECB raises interest rates to cool inflation.
Higher rates prompt banks to limit lending by settling unattractive rates.
On the other hand, to encourage growth in a struggling eurozone...
...the ECB can cut interest rates to incite banks to issue clients...
...with more credit thereby encouraging investment.